[Music]
Good morning parents. Buenos. We are
going to start already our meeting this
morning.
We want to say thank you parents for
being here.
I know this is uh a meeting having to do
with our uh with a plan, the draft plan.
And right now we want to say thank you
to Matias Segura, our superintendent.
Gracias. Uh,
we also want to say thank you to all the
leadership team that is here this
morning.
But most importantly, we want to say
thank you to you parents for being here.
I know this is uh uh you probably have
questions. We have enough time later on
as the presentation moves along.
Okay, I'm gonna pass it over to Alli.
>> Good morning everyone and thank you so
much for being here. My name is Ally
Gillarduchcci. I'm the senior executive
director of communications and community
engagement for Austin ISD. I just want
to run us through the agenda so everyone
knows what to expect. So, we have our
welcome, of course. Um, we're going to
go over some meeting norms and the
purpose of today's meeting. Um, we'll do
some introductions because we have some
folks here to answer some various
questions you may have. Um, we're going
to give you an overview of what is in
the proposed plan so that we know that
everyone is on the same page about what
we're proposing. Um, and then we you
guys some of y'all submitted comment
cards via this QR code that's on the
table. Um, and so we pulled some of
those questions and comments that have
already been submitted. Um, this is open
until October 28th, so there's still
time to get your ideas and comments in
there, but we pulled some in advance so
that we could respond to those questions
today. And then we'll take questions
from y'all that you have today as well.
Um, and then we'll talk about next
steps.
Um, and so here's some of our meeting
norms. We want to we're we're working to
build the future together. And that
means acknowledging the challenges of
the situation that the district is in.
But we also want to focus on ideas and
solutions that make our district
stronger, more equitable, and
sustainable for years to come. We want
to honor time. We're going to ask that
each speaker um both our speakers as
well as y'all. Try to limit your
comments to about a minute so that we
can make space for everyone. We want to
honor each other and speak respectfully
to one another. We want to honor our
process. We are trying to be really
thoughtful about how we create this
space so that we can have um a healthy
dialogue. Um and we want to honor intent
and impact. That means that we can
disagree on ideas but we want to assume
positive intent that everyone wants the
same things which is what is best for
our kids to support them in their
futures. Um we want to honor space and
voice. So if you've already spoken once,
we'll call on other people before we go
back to the same person twice. And we
want to try to stay solutionoriented um
discuss focusing on ideas, solutions and
understanding. Um and we are trying to
embrace transparency and empathy. We
know these are difficult conversations
but we are going to share with you
everything that we know um as we are
going through this process.
[Music]
And here's our those same norms in
Spanish.
Um, and so for the purpose of our
meeting today, we want to first and
foremost respond to some of the
questions that were submitted because we
know these are we saw some questions
that came up a few different times in
the comment cards. So, we're going to
respond to those and make sure that
y'all have an opportunity to follow up
and ask follow-up questions or new
questions you may have thought of. We
want to make sure that we all have a
shared understanding of what is being
proposed and all the implications. Um,
and then we as district leaders want to
gain insight into your experiences, your
concerns, your ideas to help inform any
potential changes to the plan because we
will be create uh creating a draft revi
or a revised version of the plan um
that's going to be released October
31st. And so the ideas that we hear from
y'all help us shape the plan and make it
work better for y'all and for the
district. Um, so with that, I'm going to
go ahead and um share pass it over to
our superintendent, Matias Sagur, who's
going to talk to you a little bit about
the vision and the why behind this
process.
Hola, Matura, soy, superintendent, the
Austin ISD. I'm Matias Sigura, the
superintendent for Austin ISD, and I
want to thank you uh for being here this
morning. Your presence, your love for
your students, your advocacy for your
school and your community means
everything. Uh I want to also just
recognize how harmful, how disruptive
all of this is.
It's not easy.
I also want to share with you that there
are lots of things happening right now
that are putting pressure on Austin ISD.
But our goal, our collective vision is
to ensure that every single part of
Austin,
no matter where you live,
has access to strong, vibrant, loving
neighborhood schools.
That's the goal.
We have great schools in Austin. This is
a great school.
But the reality is that we do not have
the resources to continue on in the way
that we have been and still ensure that
all of our students, especially those
that look like me, that look like many
of us in the room, get what they need to
be successful.
That's the honest truth.
This plan,
it's complex.
There are lots of elements, lots of
pieces to it because we're trying to
address several things all at once.
And I will tell you that if we didn't do
it this way, it is very likely
that significant burden, the burden of
change, whether it's closures or
consolidations or boundary changes,
would be even more heavily weighted in
East Austin.
I'm not going to do that. I'm not going
to sort support a plan. I will not bring
a plan forward that doesn't distribute
that change across the entire school
district. So, there are a couple things
that we're trying to do. One,
we want to align feeder patterns in
Austin ISD.
When I talk about aligning feeder
patterns, I'm talking about having one
elementary school go to no more than two
middle schools
and one middle school to go no more than
two high schools.
Right now we have middle schools that go
to four and five high schools.
You cannot keep community together.
You cannot align programming.
You not cannot build up pathways with
that type of fractured feeder pattern.
Now, we do have clean feeder patterns in
Austin. And where do you think they are?
They're not in East Austin.
So our plan addresses that. Two,
we have to acknowledge that the funding,
the support for public education
hasn't been and is not going to increase
in the near term.
Right? The cost of education has
increased. We need to pay our teachers
more. We need more resources for our
students.
All of those things cost money and our
enrollment has declined. and the cost of
education has only increased.
>> So in order to address that, we have to
identify efficiencies in the system by
removing empty seats. And we have over
20,000 empty seats in Austin ISD. This
plan does that through consolidations,
through boundary changes, and attempts
to balance enrollment. The other thing
that we have to do, we have to align
programming
so that it's sustained for years to
come. And I'm talking about our
wallto-wall dual language programs. We
have four of them in Austin ISD.
These wall-to-wall dual language
programs require really for best
practice that 50% half of the students
are emergent bilingual students
and the other half note emergent
bilingual. But what's happened is over
years as the city has changed the
numbers of emergent bilingual students
in these programs has decreased
year-over-year.
So now we have 17%, 21%, 24%, and 44%
when they should all be roughly 50%.
And so what we know is that our emerging
bilingual families don't have the same
access. Many of our families are working
multiple jobs. And so we are moving the
programs to where our emergent fam,
bilingual families live in an effort to
increase access. We want our families to
take advantage of these programs and to
do that and to ensure sustainability, we
have to move them. The other thing we
have to acknowledge that there are
incredible schools all throughout Austin
ISD,
but we live in a state that has an
accountability system that relies on a
single test taken on a single day.
And that letter grade, right, wrong or
indifferent, has significant meaning.
And we as a school system have to
acknowledge that that is the state
Right? Whether it's a D school, F
school, A school, B school, whatever it
may be, we as a school district have to
take ownership of it. Acknowledge that
there are improvements to be made. But
if we're not aggressive in shedding the
weight, like getting rid of the
accountability weight, then the risk of
state intervention, the risk of someone
else coming in and telling us how to
educate our students
will be increased. And so we have to
address the turnaround plans, the taps,
you may hear the word tap over and over
again for both 3UA, which is an
acceptable rating, and 2UA. And that's
kind of where we find ourselves here at
Bington. We're kind of in this moment
where we're trying to tackle all of this
at the same time. And the last thing
I'll say is we need to address our
transfer policies. Our transfer policies
have been in place in some cases for
decades and it's created opportunities
for families to choose schools outside
of their area and for there are reasons
why that occurred in the past. But when
you have that type of movement, it's
really hard to grow and stabilize
loving, strong neighborhood schools. And
so this plan includes us addressing
transfers.
So it is complex. There are lots of
moving pieces. Every single time we make
a change in one of our schools, it
impacts adjacent schools. And so I want
you to know if we go to the next slide
that this plan uh does a couple things
specifically for Bington and the Bington
community, Wooldridge as well as uh GT
Guo Thompson. First, the plan includes
that the majority of students at Bington
will be re reassigned
to Guo Thompson.
So, the reason that that assignment is
important and why it's the majority, and
we'll talk about this a little more
detail, is that the state of Texas
requires
by way of a turnaround plan as one of
the options to reassign the students to
a school that is
higher performing. Right? And again, the
reason that our schools are are
performing the way they are is because
of Austinite. It's because of the the
us, not our students. Just to be clear,
it is our system, not our students. But
I have to break that accountability
chain. I have to. So, we're at a moment
where the majority of students based on
where they live will go to Gro Thompson
and the other students will go to
Woolridge. Woolridge will also get
support. It'll be a modernized school.
And so in this way we can reduce the
number of seats in the area because you
always look at an area and at the same
time address the state turnaround plan
requirements and these are requirements.
We cannot miss the date. If we do or if
our plan isn't accepted, the state can
take interventions up to installing a
board of managers which means your
trustees, superintendent, the majority
of leadership changes. and we know what
disruption does to this community to to
our entire city. And so I'm going to um
to to pause there. I know we're going to
go through some other comments and
questions, but I just want you to know
um this is a draft plan. It will refine.
Your input is valuable. The team is
working every single day taking input
and thoughts and feedback. What I want
to say though is that we have to make a
decision. This is urgent.
It may feel like a compressed timeline
like everything's happening fast, but we
have been working on this for some time.
And what I do not want to take away from
our families is time to plan.
If you do not if we do not make a vote
or do not take a vote in November,
then the systems that we have to enroll
our students, the staffing, the hiring
of the principles, all of those things
that occur will be delayed
and it will not ensure that we have a
successful start of the next school
year. I will not introduce a change or
make a change in the spring semester.
It's too disruptive.
So I I just want you to know when people
ask like why the timeline why the
timeline will one of the timelines is
set by the state but also we're already
well underway planning for next year and
if we slow it down it will be very very
disruptive to our families and to our
students.
>> Good morning everyone. My name is
Christine Steenport. I am the operations
officer for Austin ISD. And so I'm just
going to kind of bring you into real
quickly what does this mean and so we
can really get to the meat of the
questions today because that's what
we're here for are your questions and
answers. So want to talk about what does
this mean for my child next year. So um
if this proposed plan was voted yes then
this would be in effect for the next
school year which would start in August
of 2026. So just wanted to kind of level
set with our timeline. Um, so if you
live in the b the Bington Elementary
current boundary, you can either go to
Guerrero Thompson Elementary School or
Woolridge Elementary School based on
your address. And I'll show a couple of
maps of what that looks like. And we
also have um I think it was on the slide
previously, it is a school map locator.
So if you can't see the map and you're
saying, I want to type in my address and
understand where my new boundary would
be, you can type in your address there.
And then at the end of this, we'll have
a lot of resources of where everything
we have, our maps, our school map
locator, anything that you want to look
through and we'll go through that to
make sure you understand where those uh
items are located. If you are a transfer
student, I'm not sure if we have any
transfer families here. Um, but if
you're a transfer student to Bington,
you can return to your zone school or
apply to a transfer with another campus.
We understand that there are some
students that if you're a transfer, you
feel that you're a community of Bington
and you want to move with the community
of Bington. And so, um, we will have,
uh, ways for those for those families to
do so if you are a transfer. Next slide,
please. So, this is the current boundary
of Bington Elementary right now as it
currently is. So if you live within this
area, you currently go to you are zoned
to Bington Elementary. In the in the
proposed plan, what we have here in
yellow, if you live in this zone of the
bound of the boundary for Bington, you
would be then zoned to Guerrero
Thompson.
If you live in this zone that is hatched
in red here, then you would be zoned to
Woolridge Elementary. So I just wanted
to make sure that was clear of what that
what that looks like. And we have that
on all of our information and we can go
over that as well.
>> Yes. Thank you.
>> The street that's divided. Um let me see
here. Right here.
I think that's the creek. Walnut Creek.
>> Walnut Creek.
Yep. If you're north of Walnut Creek,
you would go to Guerrero Thompson and
which is right here. So, we know that
right right here we're in Bington.
Guerrero Thompson's right down the
street here. Um, and then Wooldridge
Elementary is over here. And so, if you
live in this zone, it would be Woolridge
Elementary.
Okay, next slide. Okay, what would this
mean for our turnaround plan? So, I'm
going to hand this over to Ally to kind
of talk through that of what that means
for Bington.
Thank you so much, Christine. So, if you
all have been involved in the
conversations, we've been having
conversations since maybe early
September about the turnaround plan that
that our superintendent was talking
about. And that is the plan that the
state requires us to put in place for
Bington because of the three un he
called those UA the unacceptable
accountability ratings. Um, so Bington
had received three years in a row of
unacceptable accountability ratings. And
again, that's based on students
performance on the STAR test, that one
test, that one day a year. That's how
the state gives a letter grade to our
schools. So because Bington had three
years in a row, we have a turnaround
plan. Well, one of the other rules is if
if the district chooses to close a
school, as we're proposing with Bington,
and reassign to another school, wherever
the majority of students go, that
turnaround plan is going to go with
them. So, we can't just close the school
and the turnaround plan disappears. It
has to go with the students and we have
to implement it. So because if you saw
on the earlier slide um whoops that the
majority of students are going to go to
Guerrero Thompson, a smaller amount will
go to Waldridge. The turnaround plan,
this arrow goes to is going to go to
Guerrero Thompson. So the combined
Bington and Guero Thompson students will
then adopt that plan.
Let's see.
Um and so in that um instance the
appointed principal which principles if
once this is voted on whatever is voted
on in November in December is when the
district will determine who are going to
be the principles that lead the combined
school communities. So that those
appointments will happen in December and
the the appointed principal would then
have the authority to hire teachers and
staff that meet the turnaround plans
staffing criteria. So when you have a
turnaround plan, there's certain
criteria. The state wants to make sure
that when you hire staff to support the
school that they are what they call
highly effective, that they have a
certain amount of experience and that
they're they have shown and demonstrated
that when they work with students, they
help those students grow significantly
in a school year. Um and so we have to
make sure that when we're staffing that
we're selecting stu teachers and other
staff that that meet that criteria.
um any current staff at Bington or at
that the receiving school that don't
have that criteria um that's okay. It it
means that they're probably not going to
be able to be selected to work at that
school, but we have a plan as a district
to make sure that we can find another
home for them in Austin ISD. We will be
doing a hiring freeze in starting in
January because in a normal school year
start gearing up for the following
school year, we actually usually start
recruiting more teachers from about 5 to
600 teachers every single year that we
recruit to start for the next school
year. We're not going to be doing that
recruitment process because we want to
make sure that anyone who whose position
gets is is eliminated due to a closure
or consolidation that we find another
place to place them in the district. So
that will be our goal is to find a home
for everyone that we can.
>> And and just to be clear, that's not
just teachers, it's all staff. All
staff, right? So food service workers,
custodial staff, counselors, teachers
assistants, everybody is part of this
plan. We teachers are what we kind of
led with, but I wanted everybody to know
that it's all staff.
>> Thank you. Um, and then the last thing
to note is that because Bington and Gro
Thompson would have that turnaround
plan, part of this plan is that, you
know, Matias said that this is about us
being able to free up our resources to
be more efficient. But what is it that
we're going to do with those resources?
If we're saving money, we are going to
be reinvesting them in the schools that
have these turnaround plans because
Bington is not alone. We have 24 schools
across the district that have these
plans. And so this consolidation plan,
this big district-wide effort frees up
about $25 million. But we're going to
reinvest over half of that money into
those schools. And that's going to allow
those schools to have lower student
teacher ratios, to hire additional
counselors, to hire more instructional
coaches or content interventionists to
support our students. And each school
will be able to kind of determine how
they're going to use that extra money.
But it's going to infuse those extra
in it's going to infuse those extra
resources in the schools that have those
turnaround plans.
Okay. So, we had about I think four or
five questions that we pulled from the
comment cards that we're going to go
over first just to get the conversation
started. If you have any questions while
we're answering these, please feel free
to raise your hand and we can go around
and um and get to y'all's questions.
Um but the first question that we had
that came up for us, we saw someone
commented um this is Sally R. And these
comments, some of them I've had to cut a
little shorter so they fit on the slide,
but this is their direct words. Um,
Oldridge currently has a pending 2022
bond project and are expected to be and
students are expected to be displaced to
Dolby PreK as their school is updated
during construction. So that's that is
true. During the 2022 bond, Waldridge is
supposed to get a brand new building,
but while they build that building, the
students need to find a new place to
learn while the school is under
construction because there's not room on
the site. So, this person is asking,
Bington was also supposed to be part of
the bond project, and the plan for
construction would not disrupt students
or make them move because there actually
is space on Bington to have construction
while also having the kids learn in the
current building. So this person is
asking if Bington has that extra space,
why was Bington chosen to be the school
that closes instead of I think instead
of Waldridge which doesn't have that
space.
>> Yeah. So um no one specific data point
drove the decision. Uh it was multiple
inputs. We had a a rubric that we used
to identify misalignments kind of where
we weren't operating in a way that we
probably should have intended or we were
designed to. That informed kind of our
deep dive area by area. And so when you
think about what we're trying to address
here, we needed to address the
turnaround plan as well as the empty
seats in the area and do what we could
to put as many students in modernized
facilities at the same time. And so
Wooldridge because Wooldridge will be
modernized and because um we feel
confident that with this turnaround plan
we will break the accountability chain
and at the same time mo all these
schools are slightly underenrolled we
can get to a healthier enrollment with
this strategy. The other way may not and
will likely not break the accountability
chain. Matias, can you explain what you
when you say when he says break
accountability chain, that means if you
got an unacceptable, unacceptable,
unacceptable, if you get an acceptable
rating, that means you break the chain.
So now you don't have a series of
unacceptables.
>> So if you have an F, an F, an F, you
need to get to a C by your fifth year,
>> right? And so if you get a D, it's a
pause. A C will break at year five. If
you do not break the accountability
chain, get a C or better, the state can
intervene, will intervene in fact by law
an education code and install a board of
managers, which is take out our trustees
or close the school. So, we have to
understand and recognize that is a real
risk given that we're in year three,
right? Um, so when it comes to the bond
project, one of the things that we will
look like look at as we plan together is
what should occur with Wooldridge as
they plan to receive students.
Previously, they were going to swing to
Dolby. Does that somehow need to change
because of the decisions we're making
here and ultimately the plan as we move
forward? We will look at that. We have
seen some opportunities to reduce the
amount of movement um in these
construction uh steps, but we don't have
a final decision yet until we get
feedback from our community.
>> And Matias, as a followup to this,
because I know this is something that
came up at Waldridge. Um we're I know
there were questions about because
Waldridge was supposed to move to Dolby
PreK midyear. Has a decision been made
yet about where Waldridge students will
be learning while their school is being
built? And because that would include
the Bington students that are assigned
there if the if the plan goes as
proposed.
>> Yeah. So right now the plan is to um in
its current form as as Ally said have
the students go to Dolby. We've already
started those plans. We have worked with
the city. We're starting construction uh
temporarily for the swing space. Um, we
have the ability to adjust, but we
cannot start that process like in
earnest until the board takes a vote
because we would have to expend
resources. We would have to begin to
relay out the plan. And we're in this in
between time where we want to start to
work and make sure that things are are
moving forward, but we still don't have
a vote, right? And so what we're trying
to do is to plan and prepare and
identify options so that once the vote
occurs, we can move quickly, but that
may be ultimately one of the adjustments
in the construction um swing space
solution.
So to be clear, the options could be
either Waldridge and Bington could be
learning at Dolby PreK next year as the
swing space while their school is being
built at Waldridge or it's possible if
this plan passes that potentially
Bearington could serve as that swing
space for for them to learn while is
being built. So that correct is a
decision we can't make until we have a
vote and we know for sure whether or not
Bington is going to be closing. It would
be less expensive to move here combined
and then move back by millions of
dollars.
>> Okay. So, the next question that we had
from the comment card, it is essential
that TEA, the Texas Education Agency,
not pressure Austin ISD into hasty
decisions that could compromise proper
planning and the academic support our
students deserve. We also ask that AISD
prioritize genuine two-way comm
community community engagement.
Educators, families, and students should
be actively involved in shaping
consolidation plans, not simply informed
after decisions are made. Let's take the
time to do this right. How is the
district incorporating community
feedback to ensure that the most
impacted schools and families are heard
and supported through this process? And
that's from Abby B.
>> I can start. You want to start?
>> Yeah. So, that's part of the reason that
we're here today. Um, the engagement
process for these consolidations started
all the way back in the spring. You may
remember that we had put out a survey to
help us understand what matters most to
families. We had over 14,000 responses
across all of our schools. And one of
the big things that came up there, and I
think this, you know, a lot of people
could assume this, but that one of the
big things was that transportation was a
huge priority for our families. So, one
of the things that we did look at while
we were trying to develop these plans
was how do we make sure that we're
limiting travel distance for for
families and of course our policies as a
district always is if there is a
hazardous route um crossing major
highways that that transportation would
be provided by the district. So that
that engage that early engagement
informed kind of the development of what
we called our rubric which helped us
evaluate where we had challenges in our
schools when it came to either
overcrowding or underenrollment. Um and
then when we moved on to the next step
of looking at different regions and
understanding what challenges we had and
what options we had, um that's when we
kind of developed a plan and brought
that out to the community. And so we
released that in October, early October.
And that's why we're going around and
talking to families to help understand
um what what about this plan you do you
think is has some promise? what about
this plan maybe is going to present
challenges for your families that we
need to be able to work through or come
up with solutions to better support
y'all. Yeah.
>> Um but you can maybe talk a little bit
about the the timeline. I know you've
touched on that already.
>> Yeah. Thank you, Ally.
I want our families to know that we
are desperately trying to position AISD
and all of our students to be successful
for decades to come.
If we do not act now,
we will lose precious time
because you cannot make decisions like
this in the spring or the summer or the
fall. you effectively lose a whole year.
So what happens in that year? Well, your
budget deficit continues to grow.
You do not truly address the turnaround
plans that are required by the state of
Texas.
You know, enrollment has been impacted
here and in many other schools in the
Rberg area in east in East Austin
because we have immigrant families who
are not coming to our schools because of
what's happening at the federal level.
And we have families in our schools that
are choosing not to come because of
what's happening at the federal level.
And all of that is limiting our
resources.
And so I I the word here hasty to me um
is something I want to respond to. I
would say that it's urgent. I would say
that we're being proactive. And I would
say that we're being very thoughtful in
trying to do all of this together. If we
were just looking at turnaround plans,
it would be very different. If we were
just looking at consolidations, it would
look very different. But because we're
doing it all together, we have a unique
opportunity to not have it burden any
one area of the city um more than it
than we would see otherwise.
The last thing I'll say is there are
school districts right now that are
being
um for lack of a better word taken over
by the state of Texas.
They wish they would have made difficult
decisions years ago.
Like we're not going to do that. We are
going to keep local control so that our
trustees who you all elected are the
ones that are guiding how we educate our
students in Austin. Like all of this has
to be considered. So is it urgent? Yes.
I I don't Hasty I I have concerns about
saying it that way. I do think that it
needs to be thoughtful and it is
multi-layered.
You want to
>> thank you. Um, I also wanted to kind of
touch on this last part is how are the
most impacted schools and families being
heard and supported? And I know Ally
talked about that a little bit in the
beginning. Like that's why we're here.
We also have 73,000 students. We have a
lot of families, but we want to hear
from every one of them. But how do we do
that in a way that is um is that
organized and efficient so we can get
through all of those responses and
comments and feedback? And that's why
we're asking if you do have that
comment, you do have that feedback, that
QR code, type it in because we have a
form that we can categorize and
organize. And we have teams dedicated to
looking at those two to three times a
week and seeing if there's the themes,
what we're seeing. And then if there are
themes of saying, "Hey, this boundary is
wonky. It's weird. It doesn't make
sense." We will look into that. Would
there be a change? Possibly. May there
be a change? maybe not. It all depends
on the greater impact of everything
around there. So, I just wanted to kind
of talk through the process of what
we're doing to hear the feedback and
take that and incorporate it. So, if you
have feedback, we can always take that
verbally. We're here to listen and also
our feedback form. So, just wanted to
touch on that as well. Did you have a
follow-up to this?
I appreciate you guys being here and I
hear you saying it's urgent, but I don't
think you can both say it's urgent and
you're moving quickly and you're
listening to us because I don't think
Bington has felt heard or like we've had
a say. Um, it's really like every
meeting has been telling us what's
happening to our school and there's a
chance for feedback, but it doesn't seem
like that matters because it's moving
quickly for the reasons you're saying,
but it doesn't feel like it's
community-led discussion or it's
familyled. Maybe that's not an option
because of TEA, but we have like, you
know, charter schools in our
neighborhoods trying to get students out
of Austin ISD and like, you know, you're
closing our school and that's exactly
what TEA wants is they want less public
schools and more charter schools and
like that's what we're getting. So, I
don't feel hurt at all from this.
>> Yeah. So, I appreciate that comment. Um,
what I will say is there are things that
are firm because of what the agency
requires. That's just the honest truth.
If we were a 2UA or a one UA, meaning
like you only had, you know, two Fs or
you you were further back in the
process, right, which goes back to 22,
23, 21, 22, we would have more options.
But what was happening at that time
coming out of the pandemic, we didn't
have educators. you had three
superintendents in two years. I mean, we
as a system were not
um I would say prepared to acknowledge
the changes in the accountability system
while we were going through that change.
That's the honest truth. And then the
compression like all these
accountability, the lawsuits, everything
getting stacked up created this timeline
that is very very tight.
We created our plan building it off the
long range plan, building it off other
things that we felt would give us more
of a thoughtful process and then the
state agency came in in August and said
here are the timelines that you have to
submit by November 21st being when you
have to submit our taps. So at that time
it put milestones in our plan that we
could not move. And so yes there are
things that are firm meaning we cannot
do certain things because of where we
are in the accountability process. The
fact that we have three UAS here at
Bington. Um and I I hear you. There have
been lots of comments from our community
saying Matias can you go ask the agency
about this? Can you ask the agency about
this? We have over 20 schools that we
have to develop turnaround plans for and
we do make asks. We are asking questions
and getting feedback. But I never want
to bring to our community something that
I know will not be accepted by the
agency. Uh to me that would be um it it
would be very uh disingenuous. I want
you to know where we're at, what is
likely to come, and I want to move
through that process, get feedback to
refine and to improve. But there are
some things that we're just not going to
be able to accomplish because of the
pressure from the state. That's just the
honest truth. Um, but we will refine for
you. For those that have worked with me,
who have seen kind of our approach, we
will make adjustments.
But I do not want to spend a tremendous
amount of resources and time getting to
a decision when the decision is pretty
well defined as far as what we can do. I
would prefer to spend the time in
planning with communities, planning to
make sure our staff are supported,
planning to make sure our students are
supported so that we do the opposite. I
would argue that if I have the
resources, we're distributing them
equitably and our students get what they
need, then we will draw back students
because we will have high-erforming,
vibrant, loving schools everywhere in
Austin. But we can't do that when you
have 116 schools and 70,000 students.
It's just we're just too too thin. We
don't have the resources. So, I I hear
you and I apologize. I would say a lot
of it is kind of compression. Uh but we
genuinely want to engage. It's just that
this process limits what we can offer
and and really what routes and paths we
have.
>> And Matias, I'm just going to add to
that because you referenced the long
range plan and I want everyone to
understand. So the long range plan is
the kind of it was the building blocks
of the 2022 bond. That work was
something that was done over the course
of almost two years. Um, and but it got
us the 2022 bond where over 80% of the
investment was in our title one or our
more economically disadvantaged parts of
the city because the district had not
historically invested as much. The work
that we did, that's probably some of the
most um some of the work that I'm most
proud of that this district has done in
terms of how that work was driven
because we went out to like every one of
our schools. We listened to families in
small groups like this and they told us
what's working, what's not in their
schools and that was what drove the
long-range plan and many of the things
that are in this plan about making sure
that our programs are placed in the
communities that they're intended to
serve so that our Spanish speaking
families are getting the high quality
instruction and bilingual teachers that
they need. Um to make sure that we have
access to high quality program in all
parts of town. the balancing enrollment
where you have some schools that are
very underenrolled and they don't have
enough staff to support their students.
All of these things are things that we
heard directly from the community
through that process and are things that
this plan attempts to address. So, while
we don't have the timeline of two years
like we had for that plan, it is very
informed by things that our community
and our most under historically
underserved communities have told us
were problematic and that we're trying
to address in this plan. I think we have
two more questions from the comments.
Um, so how are you considering the
long-term impact on the children in the
community? Bington Elementary has always
been a place of pride, a beacon of
stability, care, and positive energy.
And this is something, it was a comment
that came up from multiple people. And
I'm going to read it along with the next
one because there's a kind of a tie to
it, but um, somebody Sarah F asked,
"Please make sure that the city of
Austin parkland that was condemned in
advance of modernizing Bington is
conveyed back to the city of Austin for
parkland as was originally intended. Um,
the joint use facility website says that
the condemnation was only done for
construction purposes and that the
intent was to reestablish a joint use
park under city of Austin ownership. So,
can the district make a clear statement
at this time that the community will
that this will happen and that the
community will get the park land back at
Bington, whatever comes of this process.
Thank you for this question and I
appreciate this question because when we
started the bond project of you know the
building of Bington this is a part of
what we had to do and there are other
schools in Austin ISD that have shared
joint use with parks and recck
department and so Bington is one of
those and so what we had to do was
condemn that part of the land for parks
and wreck for us to be the full owner
because at that point we were partial
owner to be able to build on on that
other site.
So what we do in the future with Bington
property will be up to what we call a
public facilities corporation and so
that is a board of directors that is
some of our board members and some
community members that serve on that and
we will have to build a process to see
what we do with our unused sites if you
will. So we'll have several unused sites
that were former schools and we can do
one of three things. We can sell the
property, we could lease the property,
or we could repurpose the property. And
so, if you know some of our schools,
we're doing some of those things at Peas
Elementary, the former Peas downtown,
that is something that we're working on
repurposing. And when I talk about that,
we are um partnering with United Way to
make affordable child care there. Do we
have it there yet? No. Are they under
construction? Yes. They have getting
their permits. They've got a grant from
the they've got a federal grant to
partner with us. So, we still own that
property, but we're repurposing it to be
affordable child care site. So, it's
it's really up to the future of what the
site of Bington looks like and those
other sites, and that will be deemed by
our our our PFC and our board of
directors.
>> Yeah. When it comes to um our students
taking care of our children, that that
is what we need to focus on. uh the
feedback that you provide, the work with
our principles, the work with our staff
is all going to inform our transition
plan and what we do as an organization
moving forward. Like these communities
are all very connected. We want planning
to occur collaboratively so that we
spend time not only the rest of this
semester but into this spring semester
thinking about how do you precisely
address the question just before this
which is what do our students need
moving forward and what does stability
look like to honor the legacy at Bington
to honor the work here to honor the
communities it will look different for
every one of our schools that's going
through a transition and I'm committed
to making sure that we engage with you,
we work together, and we ultimately get
to a plan that can be supported, can be
executed because we have to have the
funds to do it and moves us in a
direction towards having strong
neighborhood schools throughout Austin.
>> All right, you can just go to
>> So, that was all for the presubmitted
questions. Um, so this is just a
timeline of the school consolidation
process. Um, so phase one, like I said,
had started back in April. We're now in
phase three. We had released the draft
plan. We're doing the digital um
engagement which is on those comment
cards and inerson engagement like this.
I'll get right to you when I'm done with
the timeline. Um that the the next um
big date we actually our board just
added a workshop where they're going to
be publicly discussing the draft plan.
On November 6, they're going to have a
conversation about the revised version
of the plan. So we're going to be making
after all these conversations we're
having, we're making edits to the plan.
We'll talk about that revised version
and then the we'll have a final vote on
the plan on November 20th. So, I just
wanted to make sure everyone had that
those kind of dates in their mind. Um,
and we we do have a hard stop at 9:30,
but that gives us about 35 minutes that
we have for um questions from y'all.
transferridge.
I understand the question, but you want
>> Did you Okay.
>> Um, so my my son or my child um is in
the life skills plan program here at um
Bington and um I want to know what's
going to happen to him because does not
have life skills or that program at this
time and I I know that we're splitting
them between Waldridge and Guerrero and
so what's going to happen to my son and
being in that program
does not happen.
>> Okay. Okay. And so we also have someone
from our um Dr. Cherry Lee who is our
assistant superintendent of special
education here. So she can respond to
that. Thank you for that question. It's
an important one and thank you for
advocating for all students that are
receiving special education services.
So your child's special education
services are going to continue in this
school district. If your child is
receiving speech therapy or occupational
therapy, physical therapy, nursing
services, he will continue to receive
those services. And and you indicated um
specifically about life skills, right?
And so you're saying that the life
skills services are not uh currently
being offered at this school that your
child may be moving to. So what we're
doing at the district level is we're
looking at all of the programs and
services and staff members that are here
and we're going to ensure that those
services move to the other campuses to
the receiving campuses. In some
circumstances,
there may be situations where your child
would be receiving specialized service
like life skills or early childhood that
may not be at the new campus and we may
be looking at another campus.
In this situation, because like you
said, there is life skills here and
there. Students receiving those
specialized services.
Most likely those services are going to
be provided at that new elementary
school at Guedto Thompson. All right.
Most likely that is what's going to
happen is those teachers will be moving.
So the staff members that are here will
be offered positions at that campus and
we'll be transitioning over there.
We'll be communicating with families in
February. You would be receiving an
email from our department that would let
you know where your child was going. And
then we would also be offering an R
meeting in the spring for you. And we'll
also be offering additional time for
your family to to visit the new school
in August to visit your child's new case
manager as well.
>> So um I have two questions. The first
one will be um why if we have a DFF
we were the ones to be closed instead of
that have FFF just a simple please
explain it to me like a kindergarten
student cuz I didn't understand.
So um are you talking
>> irrespective of Waldridge or Gro
Thompson, right? You're talking about
any other school. Is that what you're
referring to?
>> Well, Woolridge was in the in the same
list at us, not Guerrero. Why us were
the one picked to be close with DFF and
why not Waldridge with FFF?
>> Yeah. So there are um the state looks at
unacceptable ratings as three 3Ds or NEF
or and there's different combinations.
So, Bington is a 3UA, which means that
you will have had to have submitted a
turnaround plan, had that plan um
approved, and be implementing that plan
in tier 4. because 23, 24, and 25 all
compressed the turnaround plans, we now
are in a situation where uh the
submissions for those um kind of come
into conflict with how we would
typically do it because you're building
the plan while you're kind of
implementing in year two. And so that's
that's what happened. When it comes to
movement of students, we think about
okay, where uh where are our students
currently? where are they moving to and
what school is going to receive the
majority of the students. So if we like
so Bington has historically performed
well and so that's why the majority of
the students here are going there. So we
could you know have more students going
there. The challenge that we run into is
we begin to introduce um different zones
and perhaps a um student population that
is so big that it ends up um not being
um being able to be supported long term.
So it's not necessarily Woolridge and
Bington. It was always Guro Thompson and
Bington. And once we were clear like hey
this is what we can fit. this is what
makes sense based on the boundary, the
creek. Then it became um that split. It
was never about one school over another.
>> Okay. Um I think you didn't answer my
question. Maybe I didn't explain it
correctly.
>> Well, I want to make sure we're clear on
the the number of D's and Fs for each
school because I I think that's the
challenge.
>> I think one to answer succinctly to the
state, a D and an F are both
unacceptable, right? And so it doesn't
>> correct.
>> So because Waldridge So I'm to repeat
her question. She was asking because
Waldridge also has those three
unacceptables. Baldridge also has a
turnaround plan, right? And so the
Bington turnaround plan is going to go
to Guerrero Thompson and the W when and
the students from Bington that get
assigned to Waldridge will be then
working on that turnaround plan for that
school, the Waldridge one. Does that
make sense?
>> So she asked why why didn't Bington have
the option to do a turnaround and keep
students here? So again, we look at we
look at all all the seats in the area
where we have movement of students and
what ultimately aligns Peter P. remember
there's lots of things we're trying to
do at the same time. And so um I know we
looked at lots of different scenarios in
every part of the city. Um when we
looked at you know the movement of
students and what ultimately
accomplishes most of the goals that we
had again aligning feeder patterns
reducing the number of empty seats in
the school district being responsive to
the turnaround plans putting students in
modernized facilities given where they
are in construction sequence. This move
ultimately was the the one that was
recommended. I will say that some of it
regarding Wooldridge um it is a smaller
student population. Woolridge is is
further along in the construction
process than Bington. Uh there are lots
of little things that kind of came into
it. It wasn't safety, it wasn't
performance. It was really trying to do
all of it together. Um you know, that's
just the honest truth. So there's both
are three turnaround plans. One will be
a reassignment, one will be a restart.
And just to be clear, Waldridge restart
means that staff, it means that um
leadership will have to go through a
hiring process. It is approved by the
agency. So it's not like Waldridge will
just be stay the same way that it is
now.
>> Okay. Yes, that's I understand that part
and I don't I don't mind moving and
starting in another place, but I was
thinking about more my students, you
know, to stay here in a safe place that
they know and they belong. But okay. And
my qu my second question is for you. Um,
this I know this is your third year as a
superintendent and I think this is your
second time in our school and the first
time was like a month ago.
>> That's not true.
>> That's not true. Okay. I I never see
you. I've been here 10 years and I never
seen you. Just like a month ago when
they have a meeting with a lot of
principles and persons and you were here
uh that you arrive a little bit late and
you were catching them and then today.
So my question is why if we know that we
are struggling cuz I know this letters
these grades were now at the end like
altogether but why didn't show up in
like an earlier or showing us like okay
what can we do better it doesn't matter
if we we were doing wrong or not but you
know showing you your face more and why
you didn't come and talk to us the staff
there were other people that come and
talk to us, the the boss and the other
person from the district. But but as a
teacher, we want to see you. We want to
talk to you. Not today. My co-workers
are not here. They are in the classroom,
of course. And I am here because I make
my arrangements, but why? If if in my
house is something is going on, I'm the
one that going to tell my kids. If
something goes in my classroom, I'm
going to tell my parents. If something
goes in the school, my principal is
going to talk to me. Why you didn't show
us? Show up and talk to us and show that
human part, you know, cuz we are
struggling emotionally. Uh cuz we have
to leave our kids behind, our families,
and our jobs. And it's not easy. Start
over. And we want to feel that human
side from you cuz you are the head. And
I don't know, maybe you can do something
better at department. I know there's a
lot of schools and a lot of situations
and you are only one, but at some point
we as staff want to see you talking to
us.
>> Yeah. So, um
I I
I am someone that deeply believes in
engaging and spending time with
community. I think if you took a and
looked at how I engage the time that I
spend, you probably would see that it's
much more than any previous
superintendent's ever spent in our
schools. And I'm not talking back.
That's it is what it is. Um, I will say
that we are at a moment where I am
wanting to be with community. I'm
wanting to have these conversations, but
I'm also having to make sure that all
the other things that we're tackling,
you know, stay um focused and are
progressing. The TA greed order from two
and a half years ago, the thing that was
going to take Austin ISD down. Do you
remember that? That is almost done.
That is almost done. We were here
talking about TEA taking Austin ISD over
two and a half years ago. We built a
plan. You all executed and have done an
incredible job. And and I I apologize
for not being here more. Um I
desperately try to be where I can. I
often tell our principles I they she
know I mean I ask our principles, tell
me where to go. There's 116 schools
events all the time. I do not want to
come into a place and ever feel like I'm
being disruptive. That's the first
thing. Secondly, this is why trust is
really important for me. like anybody,
any place should feel comfortable having
a conversation with me. Two, like I need
to know, you know, I I I try to go where
I'm needed and I and I want to be there.
Um, but given what we're tackling with
the budget, with the fact that that's
over 20 turnaround plans, uh, this is
one of 12 that are kind of in this
moment and we just went through Burn Web
and Doby. Uh, I apologize for not being
here more. Um, I I have been here more
than just a month ago. I will say that.
uh and I have been here for three years
um total uh yeah about oh not three
years a little less than three years um
in the role uh I can commit to coming
back and spending time I just will will
say that um this feedback is helpful I
appreciate it uh it's always helpful to
know what is needed from me um and I and
I I will commit to being there that's
the honest truth um but it is a large
system there are lots of moving pieces
it hasn't been because I don't want to
or I'm afraid I hope our family knows
knows I will show up every single time
our families are there. I will show up
when staff is there. I will show when
principal is there. I will show up with
anybody's anywhere. I will engage. So
it's not that I am trying to avoid a
moment. That is the opposite of what I
do. So we'll have that conversation and
I'm happy to come and talk to staff. I
know it's difficult and um you know I'll
be there for them. I love our staff.
That's why I'm going through great
lengths to keep all of our staff. It
doesn't have to be that way.
>> But I believe that our staff are part of
the solution. They're part of who we are
and we're going to keep them with Austin
ISD. So, thank you.
>> Hi, good morning. So my question is why
is not Marington given a chance and the
help that they need to improve but
you're willing to provide the help in
this case will be um will reach like for
example what you did with Adobe and web
this is what like the what I'm talking
about like the chance to you know
>> yeah so um
it's Well, it's it's not that I don't
believe that we are on the right path.
The the data shows that and I will share
I I I am confident that our system is
responding. All of our numbers are
moving in the right direction. And I
will tell you, you know, two years ago
when there were schools that are 45s and
then two two a year ago 55 and then just
this last year 59 that is moving. The
system is responding and I see it. But
to the state that's still an F, an F and
an F. That's just the honest truth. And
so with Burnit Web and Doby, we think
about well, what is their size? Could we
could this even been an option given the
way the timeline worked? You know after
engaging with communities it became
clear that the restart was the option
for Dolby and web and that was painful I
mean that was hard you know spending
time with community going through that
process was very very difficult here we
have 12 schools while we while we're
doing um enrollment loss while we're
addressing budget while we're addressing
um putting students in modernized
facilities all of it's compressed so we
don't have the ability to do that same
thing over and over and over and over
again, we won't be able to afford it.
And so all the things I would want to
commit to, we wouldn't be able to do. So
we are going to commit to lowering
student teacher I mean uh counselor uh
to student ratios. We're going to lower
student teacher ratios. We're going to
add instructional coaches. We're going
to add other supports. And just to be
clear, we have been making those changes
along the way for Bington and many of
our other schools. There are schools
right now who have 180 students, 220
students, and if you just went by our
traditional staffing allocations, they
would be so there'd be so few resources
on that campus, there's no way they
could be successful. So, this board,
this administration said, you know what,
no matter how small you get, we're going
to create a floor. And so, um, what I'll
say is it's it's a function of where
we're in and the type of change that has
to occur which led us to this decision
and or this recommendation, I should
say. Um, you know, this feedback is
helpful. Um, I would say that a restart
um is also very very challenging. You
know, that would mean that the staff
would not be here next year in the same
way. I would hear about 1882
partnerships. Matias, could you look at
a teaching partnership? That means no
staff is Austin ISC staff. And what I
continue to hear from our community is
that something we want to do. So I don't
have lots of options given the
complexity and the weight that we have
that we're managing. Um, and so that's
what led us to this. But I'm happy to
make adjustments. I'm happy to refine.
And if ultimately our board wants to go
in a different direction, then I'll make
that adjustment also.
>> Go ahead. Sorry.
But um I know that you explained that
even if we have a D you know DFF it's
the same as D FFF but like why
you willing to provide that help to a FF
in us you know that's like you didn't
you didn't answer my my question
>> so there Bington 29 2019 was an F,
right? 2020 was a a pause year, then it
was a D, then it was an F, then it was
an F. So, I want to be really clear. All
of that counts. It's not just the last
three years, it's the last seven, the
last uh since 2018, all those years. And
so, a D just pauses. So, if you have an
F before a D, the the F still continues.
>> So, I just want to be really really
clear. This goes back till 2019, 2020.
There's lots of things that occurred at
that time. And so by the time we came
together in 23 24 of the things were
already in place, right? All the weight
of those ratings were in place. And so
we have been doing the work to get out.
And y'all have been doing work. Y'all
been doing amazing work. And it's
moving. It's just I'm at a point now
with the timelines that the state has. I
don't have the options without
introducing significant risk from the
AY's perspective. And that risk is
great. It could take control of our
ability to support education out of our
local elected officials. And that is a
place we do not want to be.
>> Okay. So what I get from all this is
that no matter what we think or what we
um say or opinion like you're going to
close the school. So that's what I get
from everything. So I don't think it
matters what we say or what we think or
what we express. You know, I guess y'all
make that decision already.
>> So we arrived at this draft plan through
ma working through all of it. So it
wasn't just one element or another or we
this school it had nothing to it was all
of it coming together. So it wasn't like
uh we arrived at it by to this
conclusion by accident like there was a
process there was an analysis there was
a thoughtful consideration of all the
adjacent schools before we made this
recommendation. So ultimately will there
be refinements? Yes I am taking all the
input and making adjustments. So nothing
is final. That is the honest truth. That
is the honest truth. Um you know there
and I expect there will be refinement in
the plan. uh and nothing will be final
until the board votes. But I will say
that the turnaround plan required by the
state has to be accepted and we do have
an understanding of what things they
will and will not accept. Uh and I do
not want to put our district, our
community in a position to submit
something that will be rejected and then
put us in a difficult spot moving
forward.
>> Matias, I want to kind of just take
everything that's been said because it
was kind of tied to your question and
your question just to make sure it's
kind of all wrapped together. I think
something that Christine just shared
with me, our our operations officer, is
that in this area there's 4,800 seats.
So 4,800 seats. Then there's 3,000
students who reside. So that's 1,800
empty seats, right? And so when you look
at So then you've got what schools? You
have Guerrero Thompson which is right
across Brunberg. You've got Waldridge
which is up the road and you've got
Bington in that area, right? the you
don't have a lot of options because
Bington requires a turnaround plan that
either needs to be a closure or a
restart. Waldridge also requires a
turnaround plan that needs to be a
closure or a restart. Guerrero Thompson
is a B or
>> A and B.
>> Is it A or B rated school? So TEA looks
at that like that's the school where you
should get most students because that's
the the high performing school to TEA,
right? And so when looking at the area
that we need to reduce the number of
empty seats because we don't want to pay
for empty buildings, we want to use
those dollars to pay our teachers to pay
all the support. We had to make a
decision. And like Superintendent Sigura
said, Waldridge is was further along in
construction. I'm going to be honest, if
it was the other way around, if Bington
were further along and Waldridge hadn't
started, it could have possibly gone the
other way, right? So there's lots of
different factors that are all
constraining the options that are
available to us.
>> Well said.
>> I'd like to follow up on on her comment.
Um I get it. You're under the gun by
tea. There's nothing you can do
as far as everything that has been
discussed. I get it. Um I've kind of
made my peace with it. me and my
children cried about it. Um,
my concern now, I've been at the school
since 2018 and I'm struggling
emotionally. I don't know how I'm going
to do at the end of the year.
My heart is with the teachers. These
teachers have been there when my
daughter I have three daughters, so they
cry a lot. Um, when they, you know, when
they get their feelings hurt, when they
scrape their knees. Um,
my second grader was three months old
when my seventh grader now enrolled
here. So they have seen her grown up.
Dr. Sanchez has seen her grown up and
now she's in second grade. So
I'm I want to make sure because I think
the consensus is is is that kind of a
lot of credibility has been lost. Um the
community kind of doesn't
trust the district because of what we've
been saying is we don't feel heard.
we're kind of just being told what's
going to happen. I understand now after
hearing what you're saying that you're
under the gun by TA. This is what we
have to do. And the alternative of
having a charter school come in here if
they were to keep the school open. I
would not like that either. Um, so
my question to you is, and I would like
to have a commitment
is,
are you really going to take care of our
teachers? And because there is some
feeling that
the district or the teachers feel that
once the school year is over, you're on
your own. and I
have a relationship with a lot of the
teachers because I've been here for a
long time and my heart is with them and
I already don't agree that they don't
get paid enough and and we all know that
and we all fight for that. But I want a
commitment that they will be taken care
of because at the end of the school year
we're not going to see them anymore. And
are they really going to be taken care
of because they somehow feel that they
will not be taken care of and they're
going to be looking for jobs elsewhere
and that the district is not going to
fill them somewhere else. So right now
that's what I would like to know and I
would like to make sure that there that
it is crystal clear that our teachers
will be placed elsewhere because I just
can't with the thought of that they're
not going to have a job after all the
hard work that they have done for my
family and for everybody else here.
>> Yeah. So that is a commitment of mine
and our board has made that clear to me.
So, I have not at any point in my three
years ever at any point not communicated
my sincere appreciation and commitment
to supporting our educators. Whether
it's compensation of the last three
years, whether it's improving climate
and culture, whether it's preserving
planning time, like I I am the son of a
teacher who taught here for over 40
years. Like, I will do anything for our
educators. This plan in the documents
that were uploaded had detailed
processes for how we're going to protect
every educator. We said we recognize
that every plan is going to be slightly
different. A turnaround plan has certain
requirements from the agency. Number of
years of experience, certain
certifications. We have some um uh
schools that are going to do a program
shift, right? So, are you uh certified
for dual language? That'll be a
requirement. And then we have other
moves that are generally just kind of a
blend, right? And in those instances, in
all these instances, we have the ability
to set the hiring plan. I've been really
clear. There was a comment on some
Facebook page at some point that said,
"We are going to fire 700 teachers."
That is absolutely not true. I've never
said it. I've never mentioned it. No
principal. I mean, I this is not true.
It is a complete lie. That is not true.
Secondly, I have never in one moment
thought about contracts ever. I I didn't
even think about it until someone
brought it up two weeks ago and said,
"Matias, are you looking at one year,
two-year, and three-year contract?" No,
that is not who we are. We protect our
educators. I've done everything possible
to try to increase the number of
educators who stay with us. We're at 88%
staffing rate and 97% staffing rate, 88%
attrition rate. I mean, sorry, um,
retention rate. That's up almost 20%
from three years ago. Like I hope our
staff and community know that this
organization, me leading it, will do
everything possible to protect our
teachers. So yes, we have plans. We're
doing freezing. We're not hiring anybody
outside this school district until
April. That gives us over four months to
go through doing meeting fairs, making
sure that we're placing, getting
surveys. Our princ our teachers are
going to receive surveys. Where do you
want to go? I have teachers right now
that say, "Matas, I live in Flugerville.
I've been working down in South Austin
for the last 15 years. please find me a
school further up north. We will make
that happen. We hire almost 700 teachers
every single year. We will find them a
home. There's no doubt. Um what I want
to also be really clear about is that um
every set of um moves campus by campus
is going to look slightly different,
right? Because one of the things that
you probably want to know is who is the
principal going to be at these schools?
I have to set the principal in December
because the principal then is going to
help higher. If I delay the vote, if we
or we delay the process that now occurs
in January or February, which then now
puts immense pressure on our teachers to
go through the process and finding a
home. So this plan I have done I I hope
that you can see in the details that we
have put together a plan that is
responsive to teacher need. Um I'm
committed to it. If anybody ever hears
or says something about us terminating
teachers, that is not who we are. That's
not what we're doing. I will tell you,
if someone comes in here and does this
work for us, they will not go through
this process. They will not go through
this plan. There'll be something very,
very more just more aggressive. So,
that's my commitment and it's in the
documents. I have it. I can certainly
bring it up if I need to. Um, but yeah,
that's that's that's what we're doing.
We are 100% committed to our teachers.
So, I mean, I don't know if that was
helpful. Sorry. I just Any other
questions?
What other questions do you have?
She said it's not fair.
She said that um it's not fair to move
the students from here to take them out
of here to bring another school here on
the until they build their school that
she think is not fair. and she was
asking me if doing a strike will help
the the board of trustees to take our
side and and see us.
And that is the district fault that she
said
And she said that is the district fall
if the
job people or teenagers are in.
>> Okay. That is the fault of the district
that students or teenagers are in the
streets because lack of education. If
they don't have the like the same
system, they don't have the safe place
and they are we are breaking like what
they have already.
>> So um
it is our responsibility to educate our
students in Austin. Period.
Every student deserves access to a high
quality education, but it needs to be
done in a way that aligns with our
values.
Just to be honest, I mean, we want
students who are great humans,
understand how to talk to someone that
doesn't look like them, students that
believe being bilingual is a superpower.
There are so many things that we want
for our students. And I will tell you,
we need to lean into those values and at
the same time be mindful of the system
that we're in. That the accountability
system is real and we want our students
to be on grade level and be successful
academically. I don't have the ability
to provide resources everywhere they're
needed because there are students in
East Austin that just need more. And
that's okay. We know that. We talk about
it all the time that there are students
that need more. I don't have the ability
to make that work under the current
configuration and it has been going for
144 years. We have to make a change if
we're going to be who we need to be in
for the next 50 years. If we continue
doing what we're doing now, we'll be
right here next year, the following
year, and five years from now talking
about why are our students not getting
what they need from Austin ISD. I'm not
going to be part of that. I want to be
part of a system that is responsive to
everything our community needs and has
the ability to actually do the work.
Now, I'm not going to speak to the
strike piece. That's not I mean, but
what I will say is I hear you. I am so
sorry that we're going through this.
It's not something I ever wanted to be a
part of as a leader, but I'm trying to
do it thoughtfully and in a caring way,
and I am committed to doing that. Um,
and if we don't do it, it very well
could be done to us. Um, so I hope that
was helpful, but you know, I can't speak
to the side.
Oh, the other thing I'll say, you talked
about moving um, it's not fair for
another school to come.
Here's the thing. If that ends up saving
$4 million,
you know, I I need to be honest about
those are resources that we don't have
that we would be wasting in portables.
I would rather our students don't care
where they are, not be in portables, be
in buildings where they're secure, where
we have systems where teachers feel
supported. It so I I hear you on the
fairness piece, but I also want you to
know that we want to be thinking about
that aspect as well because I'm not if
I'm I can save $4 billion and that can
go into making improvements in
facilities elsewhere or even at that
school and and and that's that's that's
hard and I understand that. But that is
the reality of the decisions we have to
make.
>> Okay. While Ally gets the screen going,
we have a couple we have five more
minutes for a few more questions. Does
anyone have a question?
>> I must
um we are like across the street and
down two houses and we're really
concerned about what's going to happen
here. Uh you can see the homelessness
around the area. Um
We're concerned that that it will be
encroached.
>> So, so this probably makes an argument
for actually Waldridge coming over. I
mean, so because what you here's the
thing, we never want to have a shuttered
school. We want to work with community,
identify what works for the community,
and also be really honest about what
works for Austin ISD. I've gone into
community meetings and someone says,
"Matias, we want a dog park." Like,
we're I'm not going to do that, right? I
mean, that's just not something because
we need to figure out a way if we can to
generate some to monetize the asset in
some way. It doesn't mean that we can't
be creative and have an early childhood
center or have a community asset,
teacher housing, there's lots of things
we can do. Um
now if if in the event we did not move
Wooldrich here right we are still going
to um ensure that the um building
operates that there's movement that it's
protected or we have our own police
department you know we will not ever let
a a building become uh shuttered
>> but that being said you know Waldridge
coming over for a period of time would
ensure that it's vibrant while we go
through our planning process so by the
time we all move back to the new school
that's fully built, you know exactly
what's going to be here and we're
already starting that work. Like to me,
that would be a way to to do both. But I
also understand the comment that that
was just made about it being maybe not
desirable. So So that's how I would
approach it. Um and I hear you. I do not
want shuttered buildings. That's not who
we are and we care about our neighbors.
Um so thank you for living in the
neighborhood. Um so thank you.
>> Okay. So, I'm going to go ahead and show
you a few resources where you can find
them. Um, one that I was thinking of,
you were asking about the teachers. So,
where you're going to find everything,
it's austinisd.org
and it's a forward slconolidate.
Once you get there on the left hand side
here, there's a lot of there's FAQs,
there's the upcoming meetings, but if
you click the resources button, thank
you, Christine. uh specifically the
staffing questions you were asking. We
have a staffing guide book here and
there's an English version and a Spanish
version and it goes through the timeline
that we talked about about where how
we're going to freeze external hires
while we work to find positions for all
of our internal staff.
>> So, so um go this way. So, we're are
selecting principles in December. That's
important. I want our families to know
who the principles are going to be
before we go to winter break. Clarity is
kind. like we have to communicate as
soon as we know December we are doing
the internal hiring freeze and then
we're going to begin doing match fairs
in February and March and back down way
down here into April is when we open it
up but if you can go down real quick to
the next couple slides something I want
to show each stop right here each school
as I mentioned before has a different
transition plan for staff if it's a tap
this is likely going to be your your
pathway if it's a consolidation with no
tap this is the hiring structure
so on and so forth. So, we're very very
clear. This is what all of our staff can
expect. We are taking lead on that. We
actually had our meeting here at Bington
Monday where um our senior uh executive
director within talent strategy met with
all staff and asked questions and got
feedback. So, I want you to know we're
already way in this working through it
to make sure our teachers are supported
and staff are supported. Here is a
flowchart. You know, uh we have our
plans tied to each one of these moves.
Does the employee meet the requirements?
Yes or no? Then you go through this
process. But here's the thing. At the
end of the day, we were going to protect
everybody if they don't get matched. We
will find a home. We value who they are.
They're working to Austin ISD. This is
detailed. It's in here. If you go to the
next one, you can see how they're very
different based on the um needs of the
school. Um but there's a and then you
can kind of see the ratios like
everything. Like I I want our community
to know like we've been very very This
is very important to me. advice is very
important.
>> Christine, if you go to We were talking
about the extra investments in the
schools with turnaround plans. So, these
are staffing examples for a high school,
a middle school, and an elementary
school. Um, and each campus Oh, that got
quiet. That's nice. Um, each campus will
get to kind of they're going to have
extra resources and this is just an
example of how they could invest that to
better support, but they can of course
tailor it to what the needs of those
schools are. And so what we gave
examples of what it could look like, the
extra resources that the turnaround plan
schools will have. Um if you want to
exit this.
So yeah, back to the slides. So you'll
if you go to the homepage, um a lot of
if that big huge plan we released on
October 3rd, um we actually created
videos in English and Spanish that walk
you through the whole thing. Um so that
can be really helpful. Um trying to
think of other Oh, and the last thing I
wanted to show you was um the review
proposed school assignments. If you
click here, that is that tool we were
mentioning that if you enter your
address, it'll tell you what your
proposed elementary, middle, and high
school will be. Um so that's how you
find that. It takes a little while to
load because it's a big program, but you
enter your address and um that will tell
you the proposal. And if anything
changes between now and the vote, we
would update this so that it reflected
what's going to happen next year.
Um, so I think that is we are exactly on
time. I want to just thank everyone so
much for all of your thoughtful
questions. Um, hopefully that we were
able to accomplish our purpose today of
making sure we walked away with a shared
understanding of kind of where we're at.
Um, just to review the timeline one more
time. Um, re any revisions to this first
draft plan are going to be shared
publicly um, on Friday and our board
will then discuss it the following
Thursday. So that's the 31st and the 6th
of November. Um, and then that final
vote that we anticipate from the board
is November 20th. Um, so once we know
exactly what's happening, that's when we
can start making some of these questions
you asked that we don't have firm
answers on. Once we have a board vote
and we know what's approved, that's when
we can start being more firm on some of
those answers like the swing space for
Waldridge um, and all the staffing
things begin from there. So, thank you
so much everyone. We really appreciate
you and um, we will stay in touch.
you'll hear from us um next Friday with
kind of the revised version that's going
to come to you in your inbox via text.
It'll be on socials, media, everywhere.
So, thank you very much and have a
wonderful rest of your day.
>> Thank you.